good evening I'm Matthew Spalding
associate vice rend Dean for Hillsdale
College here in Washington DC
welcome to the Kirby Center in his first
inaugural
Ibraham Lincoln famously talked about
the mystic chords of memory the ones
that would swell the chorus the Union
when they are touched by the angels of
our better nature those chords if you
recall stretched from every living heart
and hearthstone back to every
battlefield in Patriot grave it's a
question that goes back to ancient time
I have in mind the great Greek myth of
Antigone who she wants to bury her
brother who died on the battlefield at
Thebes it's always been a question what
do we do with those killed in battle in
foreign lands our guest this evening has
written a book on the smallest of
federal agencies with one of the most
noble of missions to oversee 26 overseas
cemeteries honouring 139,000 or dead the
book which is called worn remembrance
the story of the American battle
monuments Commission I have to say the
book is not available because it's
already sold out its first printing
although we have you can order it and I
encourage you to do so if you order it
the school hillsdale will ship it to you
and our speaker has book plates which
you will sign here that you can put in
the book so I strongly encourage you to
do that
it's a history of those who take care of
those dead I've started reading it this
afternoon it's a wonderful book the
pictures of the site's most taken by the
author by the way are very fascinating
most of us know Thomas Connor Tom Connor
he's the William Harris professor of
military history at Hillsdale College
he teaches Western heritage and American
heritage which are two courses in the
Hillsdale core curriculum he also
teaches upper level courses
European history and the two world wars
he is one of the colleges currently
longest-serving faculty members he's
also one of the best and he's been named
professor of the year I can't count how
many times at this point and so he's
always always popular and I am
especially happy to introduce him as a
dear friend and among others
a teacher of both my wife and my
daughter so I give you Thomas Connor
[Applause]
thank you ladies and gentlemen thank you
Matt for that nice introduction you stay
at a place long enough you will be what
intergenerational in your contacts
anyway but I want to welcome you to this
presentation I hope it will appeal to
the better angels of your nature and
there are a couple of people I want to
acknowledge and thank before we get into
the presentation proper certainly want
to thank the entire staff here at Kirby
Center Matthew Spalding Matthew Morrell
Andrew Heim all the technical crew which
who or who have made it possible to
actually display some pictures the
nature of this story
I think imposes a veritable necessity on
whoever's doing it to show pictures of
these monuments and the cemetery sites
because therein lay the the real beauty
of this whole story but there's another
gentleman I'd I'd like to recognize he
he's not bashful but he may not have
been expecting this but it's a great
honor for me to have had the full
cooperation of the American battle
monuments Commission across the whole
ten years that I've been working on this
book and my chief contact all that time
when we first met 10 years ago Michael
Connelly was the public affairs officer
now he's the chief of staff at the
headquarters office in Arlington and
he's here tonight so it's like to
acknowledge and thank Mike
I want to talk about the book what's
what it it's about a little bit about
how I came to write it a little bit
about how I put together this story and
finally will give a little sneak preview
of some of the to me anyway most
interesting discoveries that I made
while doing the research and then leave
the rest of the discovery of those
interesting findings to you or those of
you who do choose to to buy the book and
I'm very sorry that it is not available
it's kind of a good problem and a bad
problem to have I think the first
printing run was a bit small so but
we're hopeful to get more books out
there because the I'm very grateful to
the Hillsdale College marketing division
they have brought their full weight to
bear on getting word out and I don't
think either I or the University of
Kentucky Press which actually published
it was prepared frankly for the impact
of their efforts but you see the title
the book it's called war and remembrance
I actually learned when I proposed that
title to the publisher they were a
little reluctant to agree to it right
away but they ultimately did you know
that's the title of a Herman Wouk novel
his sequel to another Herman Wouk novel
of the winds of war and I thought the
title was suitable and I'll say the
reasons why for that but strategically I
think you may remember back in 2000
there were a lot of Floridians who voted
for Ralph Nader thinking they were going
to vote for Al Gore so I'm hoping that
people will buy this book thinking
they're going to get one of the great
World War two novels and maybe that
might even lead to a third printing but
the book is genuinely about war and
remembrance because those two words in
in some ways anyway sum up the story of
the American battle monuments Commission
it was founded in 1923 by an act of
Congress that's five years after
the first world war ended of course and
it is the product the existence of this
agency which is now in its 95th year it
was a byproduct of the war but for World
War one and the fact that we lost so
many men overseas and then once it was
all over we had to decide as a as a
government as a people where those
bodies would ultimately and be interred
but for that there would have been no
real need for the American battle
monuments Commission but at the end of
the war as it turned out each family who
lost a soldier was given the opportunity
to tell the government the War
Department did the canvassing whether
they wanted the body of their dead
husband dead son that nephew whoever it
might have been sent home for private
burial in the States or left in what
would ultimately become a permanent
American Cemetery and one of the most
interesting findings on my own research
because you know there was a second
generation of the creation of war
cemeteries and memorials after World War
two but the percentage of families that
decided they wanted the bodies brought
home versus the percentage of those who
opted to have the bodies kept in the
theatres of war and buried in an
overseas Cemetery was exactly the same
tend of each world war 61%
one of the bodies brought home 39
percent said keep them where the
particular individual fell to be buried
with his comrades forever on foreign
soil friendly soil but foreign soil so
that's the war part of the story of the
American battle monuments commission but
the remembrance part that's the ongoing
mission of the agency the agency is
heart and soul committed to fostering
furthering promoting remembrance of the
soldiers who died in our overseas wars
but I think in even the largest sense
there in the in the business part of
there
mission as they see it is to promote
remembrance and honoring of all who have
served survivors and those who made the
ultimate sacrifice alike and in recent
years particularly but I've mike is very
proud and deservedly so the efforts the
agency has made particularly in the last
10 15 years to beef up their educational
programs and there's a wonderful website
WWE BMC gov that I encourage all of you
to go to just to see the kinds of things
they're doing but I've said to Mike many
times since the agency first began
they've been in the education business
because when you see some of the
photographs of the memorials and
monuments particularly you see they have
maps on them they have inscriptions on
them that are designed not just to honor
and remember the soldiers but also to
honor and remember the cause for which
Americans have historically fought and
given their lives in overseas Wars so
that's the war and and remembrance apart
the ABMC itself is actually two entities
it is an agency Matt Spaulding described
it as the smallest government agency
federal agency I don't know for a fact
that that's true Mike may know but for
75 to 80 million dollars a year in
spending they do their work there are a
little over 400 employees most of whom
by a large majority are foreign
nationals because the business of
preserving and maintaining the sites is
largely done by foreign nationals where
the cemeteries and monuments are
Frenchmen Belgians Italians Dutch etc
but and then there are our headquarters
staff here in Arlington there's also a a
sizeable contingent in an office outside
Paris the European office that's one of
the entities that the abmc is but second
entity it is
commissioned a an oversight board of 11
members all presidential appointees
there's a chairman and a secretary and
staffers but then they're the 11
civilian members of the Commission
they're the members of the Commission
are unpaid they meet on average what
three times a year Mike more often than
not on this side of the pond but once a
year maybe on average there's a big
anniversary coming up next year is the
75th anniversary of d-day and Mike just
told me at dinner tonight the Commission
will actually go to to Normandy and and
meet over there next spring so it's an
independent agency which is something of
a miracle you might say for an agency so
small to have avoided all these years
being absorbed by some larger agency and
there were a couple of near misses that
I learned about and wrote about in the
book but I think the key person at least
in establishing the agency as an
independent agency was its first
chairman General John J Pershing the
only soldier in American history to hold
the honor of the the extraordinary rank
of general of the armies while he was
alive some people in the army consider
that a six-star rank and Pershing was
given that rank he learned about it in
September of 1919 as he was literally
sailing home from Europe with the
mission accomplished of the American
Expeditionary Forces which he commanded
and it was obviously an extraordinary
elevation he Pershing is resting now in
Arlington National Cemetery and he is
the highest-ranking soldier in that
cemetery but you'd hardly ever know that
because he has the simplest headstone
possible for anybody to have in that
Cemetery side I hope if you haven't yet
he's buried on Pershing Hill and you
certainly find it in Arlington and go
pay your armies George Washington of
course was elevated posthumously to the
rank of general of the armies but not
till 1976 in connection with the
Bicentennial so Washington never enjoyed
that rank when he was alive the second
chairman by the way was General of the
army George C Marshall 11 stars between
the first two chairmen of the the abmc
but Franklin D Roosevelt actually said
it was recorded in a press conference
that he gave I don't know whether this
ever got back to General Pershing or not
but by the end of the 1930s after the
first collection of overseas memorials
had been built and dedicated General
Pershing himself was suspicious that the
agency might go out of business because
it had accomplished its mission but
Franklin Roosevelt told a press
conference in 1939 he says as long as
General Pershing is alive I'm not going
to touch the ABM sea and it's it's
dodged a couple of moments later in its
history when it looked like it might be
absorbed into a larger agency but it
still remains independent president
Trump has repopulated the members of the
Commission Chairman and secretary
there's just one vacancy I think on the
on the Commission right now but the
agency reports directly to the president
how did I come to write this book I've
been visiting these overseas sites many
of which you're going to see displayed
on the screen momentarily I've been
going to these sites I made my first
visit to the Normandy cemetery 1978 and
I've been going back frequently with
student groups almost annually since
that time and if any of you have seen
any of these sites you know that their
beauty is is incomparable and the
quality of the the maintenance and the
preservation equally incomparable
and I also learned because when you take
a student group to one of the sites the
personnel there the administrative
personnel supervisory personnel are
always Americans at these sites they may
notice you and so I've been able to have
many many conversations with staff
enough to know that this is an unusually
dedicated and competent group
forthcoming welcoming without fail and
they love to tell the story of their own
sites and but they also are well aware
as I was made aware myself that very few
Americans know the story so I hope this
book will get the word out so to speak
and and bring to the agency and its its
personnel and also to the site's
themselves the attention that they have
always merited another reason why I
wrote the book
the other reason well one of two other
reasons when I found out and realized
that no one else had ever covered this
subject there's there's no other book
that purports to tell the story of the
abmc I am a first time author I said
last week in Hillsdale I never expected
to give birth to anything at age 68 but
here here this book has arrived but I
had the idea about ten years ago to
start it and Victor Davis Hanson who is
a great friend of Hillsdale College and
who was at that time a member of the
Commission
I ran the idea by him and we were
traveling in Europe and without
hesitation he said yeah do it because he
was aware as a commissioner that there
was no book length history of the
Commission so and that's I I knew enough
about writing books to know that that's
every authors dream to come by a topic
that nobody else has really done
so that was the second reason thirdly
ever since I was a college student I've
been in the grips of World War one it's
it's really the event in history that
I'm most passionate about ever since I
read barber Tuckman's the guns of August
as a as a college sophomore I've always
had this yearning to learn more about
World War one but also to talk about it
as I do in about 16 different classes
back at Hillsdale College but this book
is obviously about an agency that has
had a mission through both world wars
but there is a certain imbalance I
freely concede in my own coverage of
this story in favor of world war one
there's seven chapters in the book four
of them deal with the aftermath of world
war one even before anyone knew there
was going to be a second world war the
fifth chapter deals with the fate of the
monuments and cemeteries from the first
world war while the second world war
came first through the territory as the
Germans invaded France and Belgium where
all our northern France and Belgium
where all our World War 1 sites except
for the cemetery in England are the war
came through there in 1940 and then back
through there in 1944
general Eisenhower's force and I can
actually had a stint attached to the ABM
sea in the late 1920s and one of the
most touching things I found in my own
research was a telegram that General
Eisenhower sent to General Pershing on
the occasion of Pershing's 84th birthday
September 13th 1944 if you know your
chronology of the Second World War in
detail you know that by September 1944
most of northern France and a goodly
portion of Belgium had been liberated so
Ike was able to and he'd already I could
already sent out officers you go here go
there and check on the condition of our
cemeteries and
World War one monuments and those
officers had reported back to Ike so I
said Pershing a telegram on his birthday
and said just thought you'd like to know
that the monuments which iknew that
Pershing had poured his own heart and
soul into creating he knew then that
they were were safe so but that's the
fifth chapter then there's a chapter on
the building of the world war two
memorials
and a conclusion which basically
compresses the history of the last fifty
or fifty-five years of the agency into
about 20 pages mike has already teased
me about a second book or a second
edition and expanded edition I had a
word limit when I signed the contract
for this book I did intend to cover the
later years a little more thoroughly but
had to abandon that hope but maybe we'll
pick it up again at some point how do I
do the book since there with very little
literature on the ABMC the overwhelming
bulk of the research is archival and I
learned this is a graduate student and I
kind of make a joke about it but
archival history to me is doing history
in the raw you read the documents I
handled all kinds of letters signed
personally by Calvin Coolidge Franklin
Roosevelt Pershing I handled a number of
Pershing correspondence handwritten
letters that came back from wartime
France with reports on how the monuments
and cemeteries were doing the official
records of the agency are in the
National Archives out at College Park I
went to the archives downtown to look at
records of the commission of Fine Arts
which was another Commission actually a
little older than the ABMC but the Fine
Arts Commission as some of you may know
it's responsible for overseeing the
artistic quality of any memorial built
by the United States government so the
the agency is still beholden to the Fine
Arts Commission
for approval of its own artistic designs
whenever they want to do anything on the
cemetery grounds or Monument grounds
overseas general Pershing's private
papers were a big source for me there in
the Library of Congress general
Marshalls personal personal papers are
in the Marshall Library in Lexington
Virginia I went there I went out to the
Eisenhower library in Abilene Kansas had
a wonderful week out there back in 2010
or 2011 reviewing I made very detailed
notes on the year that he spent with the
abmc and I got a lot out of that
there are archival holdings in each one
of the cemeteries there there are
archives in the European office outside
Paris I worked very selectively there
with the possible exception of the
Normandy cemetery where the archival
holdings are most extensive but a lot of
the records in the overseas sites have
not really been sorted through catalogs
so it's kind of a challenge to to get
much out of them but I did get my fair
share of nuggets I think out of out of
that material too including one of the
most fascinating events recorded in the
files held at the Normandy cemetery were
accounts of Steven Spielberg's time
there for the filming of Saving Private
Ryan back in 1997 and one of the most
moving things about that was to see
evidence that actually came out in the
press months later in some cases but
evidence of how the cemetery had
affected both Spielberg and the star of
the movie Tom Hanks they were very
candid about Tom Hanks and in fact said
that when he first arrived in the
cemetery he thought only of the the
crosses two headstones the Stars of
David that marked the grave but the
longer he was there the more he realized
that underneath each of those headstones
was a human life the remains of a human
being whose life
and cut short and I know this is part of
the ongoing ambition of the agency is
literally to do everything it can to
bring those dead soldiers fallen
soldiers to life even years after they
actually lost their lives in either of
the two world wars what were some of the
most interesting discoveries I'll try to
just throw out a couple and then we'll
turn to the slides and and I'll narrate
as we go but there was a very surprising
controversy back in the 1920s in
relation to that choice that I noted
earlier was given to each of the
families if you can believe this but the
journalistic community and there were
actually some committees organized to
further one viewpoint or another but a
lot of people who didn't necessarily
have a direct stake because they didn't
have a fallen soldier in their family
but they weighed in on the choice they
thought the families of dead soldiers
should make there were partisans of both
points of view those who thought the
body should be brought home tended to be
skeptical of the idea of leaving fallen
American soldiers abroad especially in a
place like France believe it or not that
soon after the war there was a certain
skepticism as to how the French might
treat the the internment of large
numbers of Americans so would they look
to exploit the fact that Americans would
would come overseas to visit the sites
etc but those who thought that the
bodies should remain overseas were
suspicious of the funeral directors
Lobby in the United States that that
that's the real reason why families were
being pressured to have their their
their dead family members brought back
so and it was almost an unseemly quality
to that debate not as bad necessarily as
the debates we're living through right
now in our politics but considering how
sensitive an issue it is for families to
decide where they want to love one
buried I was I was quite taken aback by
that I certainly gained a very deep
appreciation and broad appreciation of
the contribution that General Pershing
made to the work of the agency I've
already referred to that but and
similarly with general Marshall but the
interesting thing about these findings
is that there's a rich biographical
literature on both these these great
Americans but very little to nothing of
any consequence on the service that
Pershing gave the last 25 years of his
life to the ABM sea and that Marshall
gave as chairman for the last ten of his
life the third and fourth chairman by
the way were also like general Marshall
World War two generals Jake Devers who
had been the sixth Army Group commander
among other roles that he played in the
Second World War
he's the only one of the first four
chairmen to have been at every single
meeting that took place during his
chairmanship General Eisenhower
appointed him President Nixon relieved
him at the end of the 1960's because of
General Devers advanced years but then
the fourth chairman was General Mark
Clark who served for the last 15 years
of his life I don't know how many of you
know much about General Clark his
generalship is normally not praised
unless his General Clark talking about
it but he wrote President Carter a
letter shortly after mr. Carter took
office I think general Clark might have
been concerned that President Carter
might relieve him of this position
because President Nixon had initially
appointed Clark but he said frankly mr.
president this is the highest honor that
my country's ever conferred upon me to
be chairman of this
Commission so and I'm sure all of his
successors have felt similarly so that
was an interesting discovery to see the
succession of very significant and great
generals who gave their final service to
their country in this in this role and
finally I've already mentioned this but
the sort of ongoing tension you might
say between the agency as an independent
agency and the rest of the bureaucracy
which threatened on a number of
occasions to absorb it to see how that
bullet kept being dodged was a very
interesting discovery as well so I'd
like to go for the remaining 15 or 20
minutes to the slides and just talk
about what you're seeing obviously and
elaborate a bit on some of the backstory
to the images so that can convey a bit
more about the the history the agency
this is what you would see when you
enter the reception area of an overseas
cemetery a photograph of the current
commander-in-chief when this picture was
taken it was President Obama then you
have the Secretary of the Commission and
the head of the European office it was
Max Cleland and Mike do you recognized
that picture on the right okay general
general Hawkins and then underneath you
have the the whole collection of former
chairman starting with Pershing to the
left and general Frederick Franks who
was a George W Bush appointee who was
removed from the position on the day
that President Obama took office but
general Merrill McDermott choice for
chairman had not been in office long
enough to be pictured there but this is
a statue of General Pershing in his
hometown in Missouri and he
any of you know the hometown I don't
even think there's a traffic light there
it's in the northwestern part of
Missouri it's place called Laclede
Pershing left there in 1881 I believe to
go to West Point and the rest as they
say is history now this is the arguably
the most important single World War one
monument in France it's on a hill called
mole coal in the meuse-argonne of battle
area it's a hundred seventy five foot
high Doric column capped by a Statue of
Liberty and the Statue of Liberty on top
is looking out into the infinity of time
and space in the direction from which
the American troops came the battle the
meuse-argonne began on the 26th of
September 1918 it ended on Armistice Day
at 11 o'clock in the morning 47 day long
battle it's the bloodiest battle in
American history 122 thousand casualties
dead and wounded together
it's the bloodiest battle in American
history because it was a very intense
battle but it also lasted over a long
period of time the Battle of the Bulge
is a very close second in terms of the
overall casualties from 1944 45 but this
monument was dedicated on the 1st of
August 1937 General Pershing was there
marshal petah was there the commander of
the French Army during the last couple
years of the First World War the
president of the French Republic was
there and President Roosevelt was on his
yacht in the Potomac but he gave a live
radio address that the audience heard
most of the Frenchmen of course couldn't
understand it but it was something of a
path-breaking undertaking and it came
off successfully for a live radio
broadcast to actually reach its audience
the monument was erected
on the ruins of a village called Mo
Falcone and that's the ruins of the
village Church the French government
gave us the ground but we didn't really
take full possession of it until we'd
worked out a liability agreement with
the French because they considered it a
dangerous place and it probably still is
the ground underneath its honeycombed
with underground bunkers there still if
you look hard enough you can cut
yourself on rusty barbed wire even to
this day the architecture of the
monument was John Russell Pope who later
did the Jefferson Memorial and had a
very testy relationship Polk did with
the Secretary of the Commission at the
time but he was given this this chore in
recognition of the fact that he was one
of the great architects of his day the
next three shots are just shots from the
top of the memorial and as you look at
each one realize again that you're
looking at the bloodiest battlefield in
American history the monument occupies a
commanding spot you can one can see
miles from there and one can see the
monument miles away from it and all
that's deliberate Pershing one of these
memorials to be seen from miles away
because he hoped that anyone who saw the
monument would just have to come get a
closer look and actually visit it and
anyone who visited there would be
reminded of what the Americans had
contributed to the war effort
the second biggest monument of World War
1 VIN each is on a hill called mult SEC
south of Verdun
it's was in the Santee Hell sector the
Battle of San Miguel began on the 12th
of September 1918 it was the first major
battle that the United States fought as
an independent army and this monument
crowns its height
for this day first you saw perspective
from distance now you see it closer up
the next you're gonna see the view from
the memorial
so this monument was actually rather
heavily damaged during World War two by
American tank fire the Germans were
there in the closing weeks of August or
beginning weeks of September the
Americans had to blast them out of there
and the monument was hit several times
but easily enough repaired in the
aftermath of of the war now this
monument is is the third most important
monument it's on on Hill 204 which is
military language for hill outside
chateau-thierry in France about 35 miles
east of Paris the architect for the
monument was the first consulting
architect for the Commission a Frenchman
transplanted to Philadelphia where he
was on the faculty of the school of
architecture at the University of
Pennsylvania
Paul Philippe Cret was his name C ret he
designed that memorial it's DN Marne
memorial the Commission just opened up a
new visitor center underneath the
memorial which I was able to visit last
spring it's it's an extraordinarily fine
a piece of work very informative panels
and even they even have some footage of
Pershing giving his dedicatory address
at the meuse-argonne monument and here's
the ever-present map to which I made
reference earlier it's designed to
acquaint people who visit the monument
with some of the action that took place
around it one of the smaller memorials
World War one memorials there were 11
World War 1 memorials altogether is in
the village of Cantigny some of you may
know that the first division saw action
there at the end of May 1918 they drove
the Germans out of this village and then
man
just hold it against the inevitable
German counter-attack and it was a big
plus for the Americans the first time
really that we'd been bloodied in an
action that we took pretty much by
ourselves and the monument is right in
the center of the little village in peak
rd i think it is in france and then the
ever-present map and explanatory panels
again this monument is on top of a ridge
in sham Ponyo it's called near the
village of Psalm P the dedicatory
plaqued they're saying that the monument
is plainly erected to remind people how
grateful the United States is for the
service of the men in this area the
soldiers in this area this is the view
from the top of the memorial you can see
down in the foreground there German
trenches that still survived they're
actually meant to survive and this just
simply re-emphasize the point that the
agency the ABMC was very much intent to
put its cemeteries and its monuments
right on the battlefields there are our
individual panels along the base of the
memorial honoring the divisions that did
the bulk of the fighting there you see
the second 36 division and this other
plaque refers to the 42nd division that
was the rainbow division so many of the
divisions in world war 1 or organized
state by state but the 42nd division was
known as the rainbow division that's the
division Douglas MacArthur fought with
and that's because it literally had
soldiers in it from coast to coast like
a rainbow stretching across the
continent this is what the cemeteries
actually look like a very different look
from what you see in Arlington for one
thing the headstones are much higher off
the ground and they are overtly
I dare say unapologetically on a bad
should ly religious shapes Latin cross
for the Christian dead star of david'
for the Jewish dead this is from the
meuse-argonne cemetery which is the
largest
abmc cemetery in Europe there are over
14,000 men buried there and about half
the total dead from that battle and very
sad to say that no American president
has ever visited there that's perhaps
all the evidence we need to suggest how
little remembered even in the centennial
year I fear to say the Great War is for
us every cemetery has a chapel
this is the meuse-argonne chapel in
Romanesque style chapel is on the
highest part of the cemetery so there's
a very panoramic view approaching it
this palm was actually left on the altar
of the chapel on dedication day for the
cemetery which was Memorial Day 1937 it
was left there by the President of
France and he was there in general
Pershing's company this is what the
cemeteries look like on Memorial Day
each individual grave is decorated in
this case because this is a French
cemetery this is the Oise in cemetery
our second largest World War 1 Cemetery
you see an American flag and a flag of
the host country if it were Belgium it
would be a Belgian flag in Italy an
Italian flag from World War two so forth
and so on so but it makes for a
spectacular sight and all those flags
are put in by hand as well this is what
the interior of a chapel can look like
this Isabella wood chapel but again
unabashedly Christian symbols inside
inscriptions stained-glass windows and
this one I can't see them but they're
there
and up and down the walls in this
particular case names of the missing as
well each of the cemeteries obviously
honors those buried there but there are
walls of the missing each place so the
total number of soldiers honored is
actually in excess of those with
individual interments at the end of
World War one families were given the
opportunity to create a verse or some
memorable passage that they would like
to have engraved on the back of the
headstone of their dead loved one this
is an idea that we took from the British
the British created their war cemeteries
before we did and for those of you who
ever visited either a World War one or
World War two cemetery maintained by the
Commonwealth War Graves Commission of
the British government you'll see just
about every grave at the base of it has
a very moving inscription first time I
ever visited such a cemetery was in
bayou and Normandy and my father was
along as the World War two veteran and
he read about six or eight of the
inscriptions and and just couldn't go
any further they're very personal very
loving very moving but for some reason
the people of the United States didn't
rise to that challenge they're only 19
headstones in the 29,000 plus headstones
with names on them that have those
inscriptions the crosses are of Carrara
marble Italian marble with a beautiful
silvery vein to it it was quite a
controversy about that the idea that we
were going to get our material for the
headstones from Italy as opposed to
using good old American granite the
American granite Association pitched
quite a fit at a succession of
Commission meetings finally General
Pershing had to tell him in 1926 that
the issue was closed and they weren't to
come back and try to browbeat the
Commission anymore
or in fact the Italian marble came in at
low bid granite would have been three or
four times more expensive per headstone
but it was the the purity of the
whiteness that ultimately I think
clinched the deal this is the the
gravestone of the son of one of the
original members of the Commission a
woman by the name of Jacqueline Cody
Bentley she was a gold star mother from
Chicago she was one of the original
seven commissioners her son had died in
1917 he's buried in the Oise aend
cemetery and I have a picture a couple
pictures in the in the book of mrs.
Bentley and also General Pershing at
that grave when the entire Commission
went over there in 1924 to inspect the
cemeteries and the monument sites this
is the only piece of privately donated
artwork in any of the american cemetery
is a beautiful statue of an american
Doughboy given by a mother whose son is
buried in the Santee Hill Cemetery
that's where the statue is she paid
$30,000 for this the end of the 1920s
and the Commission initially voted not
to allow the statue in there because
they didn't want to have to rule on
individual submissions for private
donations but when General Pershing
found out a couple years later that the
woman in question was the daughter of
James G Blaine who was Republican
nominee for president in 1884 he changed
his mind and Pershing as a young man
greatly admired mr. Blaine so there the
statue is but if they were going to make
an exception over anything I'm glad they
did it with that one
this is Superintendent Michael Koontz
some years ago Michael has posted at the
Normandy cemetery now I believe he's
director of visitor services over there
but in 2010 when that picture was taken
he was superintendent it's at me he'll
and he's taken the flags down which was
done every day at every Cemetery to
symbolize a duty day
completed and I've heard once cemetery
superintendent say this I've read it
elsewhere that there's a belief and I
think for very very sound and poignant
reasons is every soldier buried in one
of those cemeteries resting abroad is
still serving his country by reminding
us all of the price of freedom this is
the Cambridge Cemetery in England the
world war ii cemetery now you can see a
little bit difference in architectural
style there are more rectangular chapel
building for example we don't argue
about whether a chapel is in the case of
the World War one chapel is gothic or
Romanesque with these they're more
modern they're about 3600 of our
soldiers buried in Cambridge
the majority of them Flyers and here's
the wall of the missing at Cambridge
Cemetery and there are actually more
names on the wall the missing then there
are buried in the cemetery there were
5000 names on the walls of missing two
of them would be very well known they
suspect everyone here Glenn Miller and
Joseph Kennedy jr. so many were lost of
course in bombing raids and whatnot lost
in places where their bodies just simply
couldn't be recovered the ever-present
battle maps this is Cambridge again
every cemetery chapel has a memorial an
article of remembrance to commemorate
the Jewish dead this is ten Roman
numerals signifying the ten commandments
with the Star of David and there you see
a more of a perspective but the Jewish
symbol is still there at the base of
that right hand pillar this is the
Brittany Cemetery built very much in the
style of the local parish church with
the chapel in the middle built of stone
that is native to the area
beautiful flora very colorful cemetery
it's it's actually the second cemetery
that we have in Normandy but I'm just
taking a wild guess but I'll bet for
every one person who visits Brittany ten
or twenty go to the one that overlooks
Omaha Beach unabashedly religious
inscriptions in the interior of the
chapel designed to comfort those who
visit and then finally we come to what
has to be the best known of all the ABMC
sites the norm in the American Cemetery
this was Memorial Day 2011 Old Glory
flies next to the French tricolour on
Memorial Day each of the graves
decorated with flags of the respective
countries off in the distance this
picture you can see the the ocean the
channel when our soldiers landed on
d-day once they fought their way off the
beach and up the bluffs they came right
across the ground where the cemetery
currently is located currently it's not
going anywhere
I promise you Normandy again
again
next picture is of two of the sons of
President Theodore Roosevelt on the
right hand side the grave the headstone
inscription is accentuated because
Theodore Roosevelt jr. was a Medal of
Honor winner but next to him is his
younger brother Quentin who actually
died in the First World War but at the
request of the Roosevelt family after
the Second World War when the oldest of
the Roosevelt brothers wound up at
Normandy Quentin's grave was moved
it's this pair of graves I think there
are over 40 sets of brothers in the
normandy cemetery to this day but this
is one of the most frequently visited
spots this is the new visitor center
dedicated in 2007 and Mike just told me
over dinner tonight it's being renovated
again hopefully ready in time for the
75th anniversary next year where when
there will surely be a new crush of
visitors including the heads of state
who I'm sure will be there on June 6th
and finally now this picture the
white-haired lady is the world war two
Widow Billy Harris sister Jude me Peggy
Harris is her name her husband Billy is
buried in the cemetery he was shot down
in June or July of 1944 he was 22 years
old they had just married prior to his
going off into the service for about 60
years
Peggy was not aware that her husband was
actually in the cemetery but she
ultimately learned that that's where he
was so she has made a visit I don't know
that she's able to make the trip anymore
but for a string of years annually she
would be over there on Memorial Day she
never remarried because she never really
knew for certain until she learned that
her husband was buried in Normandy that
he was in fact dead so everybody knows
her that's her receiving a red rose from
a member of
the cemetery staff and that was a
Memorial Day 2011 as well and I'd like
to end with this because her story is
just one of thousands and thousands of
stories because every one of the
headstones marks the grave of someone
who was connected to in life to a
network of friends and family and the
cemeteries are meant of course to honor
and remember all of those those dead
soldiers but it's a call upon us to do
the same so thank you very much
[Applause]